no dia 8 de março de 2004 a 15 anos
atrás eu estava no finalzinho da minha
faculdade de medicina eu era estudante
de medicina ansioso atrasado e
perfeccionista e eu estava ali no sétimo
andar do hospital da lagoa aqui no rio
de janeiro às sete horas da noite
ajudando a todo custo a tentar salvar a
vida do marcelo que eu vou chamá assim
aqui
a massagem cardíaca para reanimar um
adolescente que dois anos antes tinha
dado um mergulho desastroso no mar durou
bem além do protocolo de parada cardíaca
a gente não queria que ele morresse
de jeito nenhum ele tinha quase a mesma
idade que eu na época estava internada
no cti há quase dois anos o marcelo ele
e lembro dele chegar pra mim e algumas
vezes e e e pedir por conta do mergulho
ele ficou tetraplégico no auge da
juventude dele eu lembro deles chegar
pra mim e pedir lucas com a voz
sussurrada lucas enxuga o suor aqui no
meu rosto e pedia também pra gente jogar
videogame para ele enquanto ele assistia
imóvel naquela maca de cti e meio ao
corre corre e o apito dos aparelhos que
volta e meia avisavam de alguém do leito
do lado que tinha acabado de partir
eu perdi a vida do marcelo
com sofrimento naquela noite
a nossa massagem cardíaca não foi
suficiente mas é estranho que o que
ficou na minha lembrança e lá se vão 15
anos nem eu não consigo esquecer
não foi só aquela noite mas foi
surpreendente mente 1
dia de sol alguns meses antes
eu lembro que as marcas lá no cti e elas
ficavam viradas assim de frente para o
cti e de costas para a janela de frente
por um lugar frio e cheio de tensão no
ar
mas nesse dia de sol caiu de ter uma
limpeza no cti e a marca do marcelo ela
ficou esquecida virada para a janela
eu cheguei para examinar ele de manhã e
os olhos dele
sorriam ele mexia a sobrancelha assim
pra mim para me avisar para compartilhar
a alegria de ver aquele mundo abençoado
acontecendo lá fora sabe sentia a o sol
que aquece a pele a água que mata a sede
as pernas que levam a gente para viajar
a música que faz chorar poder sair e
entrar dentro do abraço de quem se ama
o as também dizia que na vida a gente
tem duas opções achar que não existem
milagres ou perceber que tudo na vida é
um milagre
quando a vida está por um fio a gente
passa a reverenciar o nosso próprio
corpo
a testemunhar a nossa própria existência
um milagre da vida que é sim um convite
pra gente cuidar da gente mesmo como
quem segura um cristal delicado o como
quem dá um banho no recém nascido morreu
seguir a minha vida atendendo velhinhos
às vezes bem velhinhos mesmo eu ficava
observando encucado a chegar em um som
jesus de 90 e muitos anos assim com
vitalidade física e principalmente o que
mais me encanta com vitalidade emocional
diante dos desafios da vida e apesar dos
pesares das nossas vidas
contava no final da consulta para eles
qual o segredo para chegar tão bem até
aqui e qual não foi minha surpresa
quando eu me dei conta que os que as
pequenas e grandes escolhas de estilo de
vida de dia a dia eram as mesmas que o
jornalista dan bits nerd da national
geographic mapeou quando descobriu as
blusas 11 souza zona azuis são lugares
espalhados ao redor do planeta onde
viviam e vivem a maior quantidade de
centenários com muito boa saúde e caia
na grécia sardenha na itália loma linda
nos estados unidos entre algumas outras
as pessoas dessas comunidades elas
apesar da distância continental elas têm
hábitos de vida muito parecidos e que
incrivelmente coincidiam com que a
grande ciência da medicina do estilo de
vida estava decodificando nos últimos
anos
eu confesso que eu me encanto cada dia
mais com a medicina do estilo de vida
estudos de alta tecnologia com métodos
científicos rigorosos
eles mostram o que um bom senso e as
tradições seculares já falam pra gente
há tanto tempo a gente pode ver por
exemplo a elizabeth blackburn ganhadora
do prêmio nobel de fisiologia e medicina
mostrando a capacidade do estilo de vida
de aumentar o comprimento dos telômeros
que ditam no nível genético quantos anos
mais a gente vai viver passando pelos
doutores de ordens e é seus tim
cardiologistas que documentaram de forma
categórica como o estilo de vida pode
reverter placas de gordura obstrutiva
nas coronárias restaurando o fluxo de
sangue isso visto em pet scan para o
músculo do coração chegando à sala
usar o richa desde o som que nas
neurociências eles mostraram o efeito do
estilo de vida pra melhora cognitiva
maior tranquilidade e bem estar
emocional associado a mudanças positivas
na atividade neural vistas em estudos de
ressonância magnética do nosso cérebro
a gente está comprovando o óbvio que o
estilo de vida têm o potencial de
prevenir tratar e até mesmo de reverter
diversas doenças crônicas das quais a
gente morre cedo demais
hoje em dia e isso em perfeita harmonia
com remédios e cirurgias que são muitas
vezes formidáveis e necessários mas
melhorar o estilo de vida não deve ser
mais uma via alternativa deve ser a via
primordial
e como é que funciona na prática
medicina do estilo de vida a gente
precisa dos medicamentos de estilo de
vida eu chamo assim e da ponte de
travessia pra mudança
eu vou te contar quais são esses
medicamentos de estilo de vida como você
pode colocar de forma simples eles na
sua vida mas antes deve estar passando
na sua cabeça
lucas eu até sei que estilo de vida pode
me fazer bem mas eu não consigo mudar a
neurociência tem uma resposta pra você
provavelmente você não se lembra o que
você estava fazendo é que você tava no
seu aniversário de 8 o de 9 anos um dia
feliz na sua vida a gente não lembra
mas você é uma pergunta ver se você
lembra onde você estava o que você
estava fazendo nesse dia aqui 11 de
setembro de 2001 tanto lembrar de um
impressionante
a gente tem de lembrar o medo é uma
marca poderosa ele sequestra a nossa
memória e ele atrapalha a o
funcionamento das áreas mais nobres do
nosso cérebro e se daqui sou eu com 89
anos de idade na piscina da minha casa
eu era uma criança alegre
mas quando caía a noite e ficava no
quarto de televisão assistindo novela
para tentar esquecer dos meus medos que
me dava um vazio danada no peito sabe
medo de doença
medo de não agradar medo das coisas não
darem certo medo de ter medo
esse aí é o cérebro do lucas de 8 anos é
o cérebro de lucas de hoje em dia e ao
cérebro de todos nós
ele tem uma estrutura chamada amígdala
que fica hiper ativada quando a gente
está com medo a gente entra logo no modo
sobrevivência e fica mais imediatista um
cabeça de curto prazo isso é ótimo pra
fugir ou lutar contra um tigre faminto
no tempo das cavernas mas é um
verdadeiro desastre para você correr
atrás dos seus sonhos
o córtex pré frontal que é a área mais
nobre do nosso cérebro por conta do medo
ele é roubado ele fica apagado ou bem
menos ativo o córtex pré frontal ele é
um cio para o nosso comportamento mais
inteligente mais mães foi mais
consciente capaz de tomar decisões como
a de manter um estilo de vida saudável
no longo prazo o horizonte para a gente
mudar o estilo de vida pode ser a partir
de agora - amígdala e mais córtex
pré-frontal menos medo e mais coragem
coragem
uma palavra que vem do francês e do
latim que não quer dizer ausência de
medo coagem quer dizer agir com o
coração
lucas mas isso é poesia é poesia é
ciência e pode ser libertador vem comigo
que eu vou te contar olha só a nossa
mente ela foi moldada desde o tempo das
cavernas para farejar o medo quem não
farejavam medo estava mais descansados e
não deixou descendentes
então a sua mente hoje em dia ela está
só fazendo o trabalho dela quando quanto
mais a gente se debate contra o medo na
areia movediça mais a gente afunda
quando a gente desistir dessa luta livre
e entende que o medo está sempre por aí
as coisas começam a andar é contra
intuitivo mas a melhor maneira de
escapar da areia movediça sabe qual é
é deitar na areia movediça
o peso se distribui pela superfície do
corpo ea gente consegue flutuar e scapa
então abri de uma vez por todas espaço
tanto medo na sua vida quando a gente
abre espaço com carinho a nossa criança
que tem medo e coloca ela no colo
dá um abraço amoroso a vida volta a
fluir o medo chega e vai embora mas no
tempo dele
larry b eo agir com o coração
apesar do medo a gente continua tendo e
mãos pernas boca fala pra agir no mundo
agir com o coração na frente inspirado
por quem você quer ser como ser humano
nessa curta trajetória de vida que a
gente tem por aqui agir
inspirado pelo amor amor por quem você é
e pela vida seu redor não é mudar pelo
medo do colesterol é mudar pra tá perto
de que importa pra você não é mudar pelo
pelo medo da doença de alzheimer é mudar
para ter liberdade no futuro
olha essa pergunta você quer ter saúde
para viver o que na sua vida
essa é a bússola para a gente mudar
transformando medo em amor e aí então a
gente chega na prescrição da medicina do
estilo de vida que você vai usar com a
ajuda do profissional de saúde e na dose
que fizer bem pra você o meu desejo é
que esses quatro medicamentos sejam seus
a partir de hoje medicamento número 1
como uma melhor alimentação whole foods
plant bz um nome complicado para uma
alimentação simples e que você já
conhece comer comida integral de verdade
como ela é na natureza antes de ser
industrializada e que esse alimento seja
preponderantemente e para alguns
exclusivamente de origem vegetal arroz
integral feijão pão integral legumes
folhas castanhas frutas e daí por diante
um mundo vegetal tudo com bom tempero é
claro isso mata fome e aumenta de forma
contundente a nossa longevidade número 2
se movimenta mais 150 minutos por semana
de uma atividade que te permita
conversar mas não cantar enquanto você
está fazendo
por exemplo 75 minutos duas vezes por
semana
se você puder fortalecer e alongar os
seus músculos melhor ainda mas qualquer
movimento de forma natural ao longo do
dia já vale muito
número três se conecta mais com as
pessoas e com o mundo cultiva os seus
laços afetivos
a solidão ainda é o maior fator de risco
para a gente morrer cedo
mais do que ser sedentário obeso por
exemplo a conexão humana e se conectar
com o mundo que é o que a gente está
fazendo juntos aqui hoje ainda é
disparado o melhor remédio para a saúde
o que me leva o medicamento número
quatro é hora de lidar bem com seu
stress o estresse ele simplesmente
acontece quando o que você queria que a
realidade fosse e o que a realidade é
não tão batendo e isso faz barulho e
existe um medicamento simples e milenar
pra gente serená esse barulho 5 a 10
minutos por dia para começar pra você tá
no seu lugar de consciência uma pergunta
diferente que te coloca nesse lugar
adivinha qual vai ser agora o seu
próximo pensamento esse milissegundo de
espera de espaço de consciência presente
estável para observar de propósito
o que que está se desdobrando e
acontecendo agora no corpo e na mente
na sua volta é um lugar que você acessa
rápido quando eu te peço para você
imaginar uma situação estranha
o que você morreu
o teu corpo não está mais aqui nesse
teatro ator poltrona vazia caramba
sua presença não faz mais diferença isso
vai acontecer um dia mas de uma forma
mágica você consegue testemunhar o que
está acontecendo aqui agora as cores o
silêncio as pessoas suas idéias sua
respiração a lucas então quer dizer que
você se tornou um mestre zen que está
sempre rindo
diante da realidade da vida como nessa
foto
eu acho que eu rio mais hoje em dia mas
eu adoraria posar aqui de é bonito e bem
resolvido do instagram dizer que sim que
eu atingir o nirvana mas a a próxima
foto ela revela toda essa minha destreza
de mestre zen é meus amigos a vida é
essa vida é a montanha russa a vida é
mudança a gente se conecta mais com a
vida quando a gente se conecta com a
mudança inclusive com a mudança de
estilo de vida
o poeta rumi diz que para além das
ideias de fazer isso certo ou de fazer
isso errado existe um lugar existe um
lugar plano os olhos do marcelo
vendo a paisagem da lagoa existe um
lugar lá na vitalidade dos longevos que
se esquecem de morrer
existe um lugar lá no cérebro que
transforma medo em
amor na consciência do milagre que é a
sua vida para além das ideias de fazer
isso certo ou de fazer isso é errado
existe um lugar e eu te encontro lá
brigado
[Aplausos]